welcome to this video Wow what if like
is this I need to check that bhutan yeah
well that's exotic ninja alpha yard okay
I'm playing a double fianchetto wise
double fianchetto against the Kings
Indian this is quite an quite a
poisonous line very often black players
some don't really have a good antidote
against it ok Brook be a tease play very
quickly preparing preparing a b5 yeah ok
I'm going to take care now 94th was my
idea to control b5 and prevent that move
96 it would be M the reply yeah well
stall you can try to play that but I
don't I don't really think it is such a
good idea yup it's not doing it anyway
okay yeah should I grab the bishop town
maybe before first I don't really want
him to play before himself yeah right
see 6 mm yeah this looks who came b5 is
also quite weak yeah okay it's just
playing every move instantly and
everything's great okay well maybe maybe
can do that I mean it's possible just I
go here let's grab that the bishop is a
bit off side this is some something to
to BM cautious about it really wants to
pee on g2 in this position but it's an
important pawn yes hook takes c3
the go here for he might play 97 you
know I I don't really see what else to
do
yeah that's it 794 these are the kind of
moves that try to harass me gallon so
the Fife is going to go to a seven which
is okay i wonder how should I play Queen
d3 yeah we were protecting v5 yeah this
position black certainly does not have
enough compensation for a pond but it's
a notoriously tricky well that's that's
an ugly move cutting off the bishop okay
but what do I want to a play against it
III is going to give this check like
this i don't really like maybe I had
this first analyst maybe Nyjah form or
something like that
hmm yeah well it's it's good for what
still I think Knight f3 kingi two twin
b7 I just go he fall check and whatever
you accomplished I can drop back to
deform but it still looks quite quite
good for white and there's also Bishop a
six can I go be sure basics just
grabbing more material now come on let's
do that I'm down to 140 that the only
issue has been playing really badly but
quickly
yeah one problem is between be four
bishops e8 queen bee to rugby 1 the
winning and when you get another look ok
so i just take here and then what taking
on your form yeah i'll do a dejar take
first and ask questions later okay i
need to take and now what to do b5 yeah
problem I didn't see that one
okay it's not not great that I
overlooked the idea but I still have
this dangerous be born there should be
combined with the bishop am more
dangerous than its center
okay how to do that now Luke c7 probably
and roop d7
attacking f7 and preparing the bee
pollen bush be 786 a 700 sides a
touchdown if I take it yeah I can still
take it 96 winning the rook at the end I
only hope that the deep ball isn't isn't
tricky check yeah that's not not so
comfortable
hmm okay check check check time morning
how would you do that now yeah maybe did
1 i've got 15 seconds so check should be
champion off check check check check
check check check check check check Nate
yeah probably not the most convincing
technique at the end but it was enough
yeah yeah i blundered 90 tune but yeah
I'm not not quite sure why you need to
play 15 moves in 20 seconds and then
basically have a lost position okay but
people keep on doing that okay so i take
on b5 and my lost is maybe a strong word
but it's it's already a very uphill
struggle you're just a pawn down and you
can only try to yeah muddy the water
some somehow I know maybe maybe he
managed but after he five it's basically
gone killing killing the bishop and
giving away all those squares check yeah
this is winning for white just
completely completely winning but what I
should do is not give away night with 92
I really are just over look at this
I just retweet it said this is much
easier going rook c8 next get rid of the
rook and then push the pause so easy 'um
I mean this is winning as well compass
on plus 4 so it already sees the
promotion basically yeah well then it
didn't really matter but I overlooked 92
wasn't wasn't planned I should be five
is even stronger here ok this is check
very very much enough alright thanks for
watching